this is the goal
this is the story and the writer is
doing this
what are the elements of story that have
to happen in act two oh good question so
in act 2 some people call this the fun
and games place
i call it the trial and error place i
look at it like this is your recipe this
is your i want to bake a cake
how
step one
do this step two
do this right so in act 2 we're actually
watching the character
try to achieve the goal
successfully or unsuccessfully
um so
being able to see them actually take
physical steps towards doing that thing
is what we're watching
now we're going to start putting in the
complications and i like to call it
complications and not conflict because
people see conflict and they go just add
some negative something right
but a complication is something that's
very specific to stand in the way of the
goal
right so they're going to start coming
in contact with things that are
hindering them from getting what they
need things that are redirecting them
things that are causing them to hit rock
bottom um and then you need a midpoint
and your midpoint sounds like what it is
right happens kind of in the middle of
your story doesn't have to literally be
on page 45 of the 90 pages but it's
gonna happen somewhere around there and
it basically means that something big
enough happens to cause that redirection
either i'm gonna hit rock bottom or i
have a false victory or
um i receive some information that
changes my goal so i believe i gave this
example i've given this example before
because it's the easiest one for me if
my goal was to find my kidnapped child
at the midpoint i'd find out that my
kidnapped child has already been killed
right
that doesn't mean the story is over
though because we're only at the
midpoint that means my my goal has to
change
so now my goal is not to find my child
my goal is to
find the killer
to get revenge to get justice and so for
the rest of the screenplay we're gonna
watch the uh the parent do that
right instead of looking after the child
so the goal changes something causes a
redirection
and then some people look at the climax
as what happens at the end of act two
some people look at it as what happens
at the beginning of act three either way
it's in the same place in my opinion so
you're also going to be getting your um
character up to the point where they
actually are face to face with that goal
or face to face with that antagonist so
they can win or lose so those are the
biggest beats they need that trial and
error time or fun and games time or you
know steps to their recipe time they
need those complications that get in the
way of that so they can grow so they can
redirect they need that big moment
whatever that midpoint is that
causes a new goal makes them redirect
makes them hit rock bottom so someone
has to come in and re-motivate them
right now your mentor character gets to
come in and give a speech or whatever
and keep get them going
if you're watching an episode of grey's
anatomy that's the moment where it's
like i found the new cure
right at first we thought we'd never be
able to do this surgery oh no we didn't
do well
i found this new thing and now for the
rest of the episode they're gonna do the
new thing until they win or lose or save
the patient or not save the patient and
then you'll go up to the climax which is
where they save the patient or not save
the patient so those are the beats that
you're looking for in act two
so if we used our pam from the office
and so she's at home doing the zoom
she's already now met this woman at a
store who says email me i've got this
really cool job if you want to make some
extra money
and
pam is already doing the job by act two
maybe
okay it depends on what the goal of the
episode is so if we're looking at
meeting this woman as the inciting
incident
the problem can be deciding to call her
or not
um and if that's the pro if that's the
goal deciding to call her then the
journey is going to be the decision
now she's going to have to i don't know
what she's doing to figure out whether
she should make this call or not but
that may mean that everything we're
watching in her normal every day is
telling her i need a change i need a new
thing that motivates the call because it
could be the end of the episode where
she finally makes the call
or
it could be that i already know i'm
gonna call i said i was gonna call so
that means we're gonna watch her call
we're gonna watch her get set up with
the new job we're gonna watch her do all
of that in the second act where she
figures out what it is um and then again
seeing how that may cause friction with
her current job so it really again is
always gonna depend on what's the
intended goal is is the pilot let's say
this is her this is the pilot is the
pilot about her choosing to go into this
nefarious work or is the pilot about i
admit it
what are the repercussions of it
okay so something would have to happen
so let's say so and the stuff that was
happening for her to decide what
happened in act one
no that's going to be act two okay and
only because we're talking about
television now and television um if it's
uh
in television we need that inciting
incident by the end of act 1. so now
your act two is going to be all the
stuff that yeah i decided to take the
job i didn't decide to take the job this
is why this is what's happening with my
other job and then in act 3 you resolve
and and depending upon what the goal was
um if she's choosing to take the job
then in act three we finally hear her
say i'm gonna take the job
if it was no i've chosen this job and
the problem is trying to balance then by
the end of act three we'll know what the
rest of the season is going to look like
because we just saw how this balance
works or doesn't work or maybe she
didn't find out that it was nefarious
until the climax of the episode so in
act 3 she has to decide to continue even
though she knows that it's nefarious so
it can go a million ways but basically
whatever that goal is that we get by the
end of act one when that inciting
incident happens she meets pam at the
end of act one pam says call me
in act two we're gonna either see her
call
and then get on board it or decide to
call which means now we have to see well
what motivates that because if this is
so far out of her life she would never
do something like this then that means
whatever's happening during this day
in this episode is the stuff that's
pushing her to finally make the call
okay so maybe she gets a text in the
middle of the night and it's urgent and
they've got to fax something overseas
and hey i'm really sorry to bother you i
know you're sleeping but this needs to
happen asap and then maybe she sees the
webcam light come on on her work
computer and she realizes there's like
um some type of a snooping software and
it's recording her and it knows that she
took like a 10-minute walk around the
block and she wasn't at her computer and
so she's now feeling
trapped by this job
and she says okay
i might email this interesting lady and
the interesting lady gets back to her
like midnight
hey here it is and this is what you do
here's a link
and she goes maybe she has a glass of
wine and she decides to apply for the
job
and now she's
giving reviews on lingerie it's not
horrible it's like something where yeah
because you know if we're saying that
it's in the tone of the office and that
means it's a half hour single camera so
it's going to be you know kind of light
kind of funny may have you know small
things happen here and there that could
be a little darker right um but that
means we're talking about three act
structure and we're talking about half
hours so we don't have a lot of time so
it can be something that simple that you
know i got back i got this card oh i'd
never do that and now i'm sleeping and
enjoying myself and here come these
people saying they need this facts and
this thing and that thing and i just
want something new
all right don't make the call let's do
something new okay
and so and then in act three
something entirely different is going to
happen possibly depending upon what
happened in your act two since it's all
cause and effect but because we're
talking about television
and because we're talking about the
pilot by the time we get to the end of
act three we need to understand what the
series is about
so we need to know that she has decided
to do this
and
either we already know it's nefarious or
we don't so that's what we're going to
find out in the series or
um we realize it's getting in the way of
her current job and so we're gonna watch
her try to balance it throughout right
um so we'll we'll need that information
so sometimes in pilots uh usually when
it's kind of like a whodunit kind of
thing
and a half hour single camera comedy um
they usually tie up things with a pretty
decent bow at the end of the episodes
right but if we're talking about
one-hour dramas if we're talking about a
whodunit kind of limited series thing
then at the end of every episode you're
gonna give me some new information so
yes something new is to happen so that
i'll come back to the next episode and
that new information might be it wasn't
who you thought it was you know or this
is a new person's doing something sneaky
or whatever it is yeah
what mistakes do writers make in act 2
that end up ruining their screenplay
yeah this is where you know they don't
know structure
this is where you know they haven't
figured out what their story was before
they got to the page because this is
where uncle such and such shows up
this is where
this is the goal
this is the story and the writer is
doing this
because they don't know what the goal or
the story is or they don't know how
to get to z from a
um
and you know maybe it's because they're
just a new writer so they really just
don't know how or they don't understand
structure so they're doing all of these
other things to get to z but none of
those things connect going back to cause
and effect none of those things connect
so that happens quite often and i think
that's the biggest thing
um
sometimes there is no midpoint
um and you know depending upon what kind
of story it is what the tone is what the
genre is the midpoint doesn't have to be
something huge but it's you know bigger
than your other trials and tribulations
um so sometimes people are missing that
thing that gets us over the hump because
once we get into act two and you get
into those those trials and tribulations
if it's
uh take a step fail take a step fail
take a step fail by the time they're
doing that the fourth time i'm no longer
invested
you know what i mean i need something
that's going to change this thing to get
us going in the story so it goes back to
you know having that friend or cousin
who's really great at telling stories
right they know how to hook us in make
us think that this one thing is
happening and then take us to the next
thing right so that midpoint kind of
gets us over that hump of they've been
trying and failing or trying and
succeeding and here's something that's
going to change this whole thing for us
so that the pacing can kind of start to
rev up and we can get to the climax
so a lot of times that's missing also
the climax is missing but more so in
television pilots that i read than in
features it seems like future writers
kind of understand a little bit more
that there needs to be this high point
in tv because people are thinking about
the series and if you're writing a pilot
then you're you know creating a world
and characters that people can be
invested in they sometimes forget about
the structure of it and forget that yeah
but we're still telling a story so i
need them i need we got to get up
right and so a lot of times that's
missing and so if you're writing um a
half hour single camera comedy that
means or a dramedy then you have three
acts so your climax is gonna happen at
the end of act uh two or at the top of
act three depending upon how you write
it if you're doing a one hour drama and
let's just stay in the five act place
because there's a four act that exists
in the six act whatever let's stay in
the five act place then it's gonna
happen at the end of act four or top of
act five depending upon how you write it
so a lot of the times in tv there's just
it never makes it to a peak it just kind
of stays here the whole time and no
matter what stories you're telling
pilots features uh even if you're
writing a spec and you're doing an
episode of something we're looking for
stories to do this we're on a roller
coaster so we don't want to spend our
whole time like this we don't want to
spend our whole time like this we don't
want to spend the whole time like that
we have to have all of it happening if
not it's not a fun ride and no one wants
to get on it
and so uncle gus's method would be he
would just be
selling too much sort of sidebar detail
that we don't need whereas the other
person at the let's say the family
barbecue they have like a a b and c a
very clear point very clear points a
very clear path and by the time uncle
you know gus is done and you ask uncle
gus so what happened he probably
wouldn't even tell you the same story if
you asked again right because he's just
talking about everything and doesn't
know you know his his point his end goal
right or he gets to the end goal but
we're all lost because none of the stuff
between when he started in the end goal
made any sense because they're not
connected everything has to be connected
right and the other cousin knows how to
make a connect to b connect to c connect
to d uncle gus is saying a g
you know e m and it's like wait but what
happened to b and c and d you know i got
missing something like give me this
other information and he's cracking
himself up no one else is laughing
because we miss the joke you know what i
mean yes that kind of stuff that starts
happening